i wanted to talk about um
why i think string theory is probably
right
um i'm not string theorist i'm a
cosmologist
[Music]
there is this debate
it's uh to an extent it's a debate
within the scientific community it's
probably more of a
debate it's given is given more credence
i think by the public than within
science itself but you know what is the
correct theory of say quantum gravity is
it string theory or is it one of the
suggested alternatives and
i'm in a string theory camp and i wanted
to sort of
say why really
so string theory basically
in a nutshell postulates that
all the building blocks of nature so you
normally think of these as being like
little particles string theory says that
well no they're not little particles
they're little
tiny strings so those strings can be
either closed string so they're like a
loop a loop of string or um or they're
open strings so there's like an
extensive string and the different modes
of vibrations of those strings give you
the different particles that you that
you perceive in nature but even a string
is longer than a particle so wouldn't a
string need to be made of particles
no it itself is the fundamental object
and when you look at it from it from uh
far away it looks like a particle
because you take it so far away you
can't you know sort of resolve resolve
the distances but but um yeah i mean
fundamentally it's a string and you
can't break it
down any further it would be the
fundamental objective of nature there's
this sort of the old aristotle an idea
that you know you break things down
further and further and of course he he
postulates that you reach the atom right
of course now we get to the atom and
then we go we know you could go further
you could break things down even further
well actually there is a point where
that stops it stops at the string that's
it there's no breaking down of the
string
if you look at why where the problems in
quantum gravity arise
it's when um you have point-like
interactions so when things are
interacting at a point particularly when
gravitons are interacting at points
um and things that couple the gravitons
when that happens you get
divergences you get infinities and these
are infinities that you can't handle
sometimes you get these sorts of
infinities in other theories as well
within the standard model for example
but you can handle them right in
something called renormalization you
can't handle them within
just gravity
so what string theory does is very
loosely it sort of resolves that
by instead of things interacting at
points where they can't interact at
points anymore because the string has
extent it gives everyone a bit of
legroom
if you like yeah yeah it does but but
what's important to realize is is the it
wasn't like that was the order of the
argument okay it wasn't like somebody
just said okay well let's just give it a
bit of extent and that's going to fix
everything it's it's like you know
let's imagine everything's made up of
strings instead of particles it's like
why strings then why not just something
different white you know snowflakes
whatever right
it wasn't that it these were plucked out
of thin air there was a natural
progression that led to this this idea
and i think that that's what that's what
really convinces me
one of the things about theoretical
physics is that you know on the one it's
not like we just sort of come up with an
idea and then ask experiments to come
along and maybe a hundred years after
we've died to verify it
it's not like there's not an anything
goes attitude physics is a
it's it's an old field now it's it's
it's more mature it's been around for
longer than say biology so
we've learned to develop a lot of rules
of the game that we we can't mess with
these rules tell us what we're allowed
to do next even before we even go to an
experiment because those rules came from
experiment themselves right so in
particular
the two big guiding principles that we
have are
special relativity and quantum mechanics
and just those two things
when they come together they really
restrict what we're allowed to do and it
leads you very naturally to something
like string theory
why do people some people not like
string theory well string theory
it's hard
is the bottom line right it's
maybe it's predicted lots of things but
but in terms of actually like one of the
things that you wanted originally from
string theory was
um a unique solution of string theory a
unique solution of string theory that
describes say our universe is compatible
with our universe
now
string theory hasn't achieved that
but what you actually get out of string
theory are loads of different possible
scenarios loads of different possible
universes truly gargantuan number
and ours could be one of them ours is
compatible with one of them but there's
no unique solution so you actually get
this landscape so a lot of people don't
like that it makes they argue that maybe
you lose productivity
at the end of the day what you what we
really need is to once we can understand
the mathematics of the landscape more we
can start to make concrete statements
but it's at this stage we're not at that
level and the math is tricky but it but
but because of the trickiness of the
math string theory has also brought lots
of uh important developments with it
within maths as well
but the reason i like it is as i said is
the sort of there's a very natural
progression of an idea that leads
towards it and it's it's the same thing
that led inevitably to the to the higgs
actually it's the same logic that led to
the existence of the higgs when people
talked about
why
the higgs exists
right they talk you know usually talk
about all right because it gives mass to
particles or or if they've been a bit
more sophisticated they might say all
right because this symmetries are broken
and all that's true
but the real important thing about the
higgs is that it allows our theory of
nature to obey the rules of special
relativity and quantum mechanics in a
very particular way what you get when
you when you um consider
relativity and quantum mechanics
together you get a theory called quantum
field theory which is the most
spectacularly beautiful theory that that
we've produced it's
remarkably well um
yeah you know
well tested it's it's it's it's a great
theory right
what are you really doing when you when
you do quantum filter when you're
looking at how particles are interacting
right so you might be interested in how
electrons are interacting so you fire
two electrons each of it and you ask
what's the probability that they they
scatter by a certain amount that they
scatter through a certain angle
and when you do that you
use quantum field theory to do that it
calculates something called an amplitude
and that amplitude tells you something
about those probabilities
and when those electrons are interacting
they
quantum field theory tells us that they
exchange a virtual particle which is the
photon it's not a real particle it's not
a particle that you can grab and hold it
it's a virtual particle
so it has real effects it causes the um
electrons to scatter but but it's not a
real thing you can scatter these things
and you use quantum filthy to calculate
these amplitudes and to extract
probabilities and when you do that for
the electron you get
a sensible number okay you get a nice
number which is nice and small so that
we can retain perturbative control over
our calculations and we can we can
everything sensible okay
the trouble arises when you start
introducing w bosons which are a
different type of particle which is
another particle
w bosons have have mass
that means that they have an extra
sort of component that they would that
they have that they that they wouldn't
have if they didn't have mass so they
have this extra component which is kind
of like
there because it's got mass and this is
the longitudinal component
and when you scatter the longitudinal
components of w bosons
something goes wrong
it's all fine at low energies the low
energies it's fine
a high energies these out you calculate
these amplitudes and the numbers get big
they get big big and they translate
ultimately to probabilities exceeding
one this is completely breaking down the
quantum mechanics so this tells you
immediately that something's got to give
right so you're like well what can i do
so you look what you what you can do is
is you can look at the expression the
formula you've got for your amplitude
and you can say right it's cool at low
energies i need to fix it at high
energies so i just change the formula
okay i just fix it i just change the
formula but then you say well can i
change it in any old way just so that it
works well at high energies as well but
you can't just do anything again
quantum mechanics and relativity come
and they tell you there's only certain
things that you can do you can't just do
anything
so
they tell you to look for where the the
poles where the where things blow up in
the amplitude look for the locations of
these poles and look for the properties
of these poles these poles are where
kind of the amplitude sort of spikes up
if it spikes up you know when you
approach it from one direction if it
spikes up in one direction that's good
if it spikes up in the other direction
that's bad because what what are these
poles they're telling you about when you
do these experiments about producing a
real particle not just a virtual one but
producing a real one and they tell you
about the properties of those particles
and if their spikes are in the wrong
direction that means you've got a bad
particle a particle that's inconsistent
with quantum mechanics a particle that
will lead to negative probabilities and
all kinds of madness you do this and you
can do this in a in a way that's
consistent for the w bosons right and it
turns out that the particle that you
actually introduced into the game
was the higgs so it softens everything
up and everything's well behaved so this
is the lesson from higgs now let's play
the game of gravity this is where string
theory comes in in gravity you have
gravitons right these particles of
gravity if you like and you can scatter
them as well you can ask what happens
at low energies everything's fine
at high energies
things start to get big and start to
blow up and
this makes a nonsense of your
probabilities again so things have gone
around quantum field they've broken down
you know
you've lost control and this is this is
what goes wrong with gravity so you can
say right i've got this formula again
for the amplitude can i play the same
game okay can i just say right i'm gonna
rewrite the formula so that i improve
its behavior at high energies whilst
keeping the same behavior at low
energies so they did it and they say but
then you can't just again can't just
write anything because you've got to
check where are the poles what are the
what kind of new things have i
introduced right are they consistent
with quantum mechanics and you try and
you try and you try and it's really hard
and it seems to be like there's nothing
you can do and then one day these guys
virusoro and shapiro come along and they
come with an answer and it works
it doesn't introduce any crazy new
particles it introduces perfectly
well-behaved new particles and it's like
well that's worked right it seems to
have the same it reproduces what we want
to see at low energies it has manifestly
good high energy behavior it's
consistent
it doesn't introduce any pathological
new species of particle or anything like
that it's great and in the if nearly 50
years since this was found
nobody has come up with
an alternative
right
now
i haven't mentioned anything about
strings at this stage i
and this is the beauty of it this is the
beauty of it all this was done before
anybody mentioned the word string right
but now you look at the formula that
you've got
and you say can i interpret it and you
look at it and you realize that actually
it's a formula that describes not the
scattering of particles but really
the scattering of strings
so it wasn't that
somebody said oh let's try strings that
was never what happened
you know you had this formula you you
thought let's fix the formula okay let's
try to guess what the how things going
to behave at hand what it has to do and
this is kind of almost a unique answer
for what it could do and there you go lo
and behold it was string theory all
along well originally of course
historically they were they were looking
at other things they were looking at
things trying to explain the strong
interaction
but there's this logical argument that
you can apply to gravity and you realize
that actually the um
out pop strings it's not like you try
strings
out pop strings now of course there are
certain assumptions that i'm making here
like that
you're doing a very standard way to try
to extend the theory into into the uv
and you're keeping everything weak
coupling that means that the
interactions are not getting too strong
so there are some assumptions in what
i'm saying but
it's a very natural progression of ideas
that lead you
along one path
and that's the string thing and that's
why i
buy into it really
i think most people do bite into it i
think i think
i think most people do there are a
community which
which don't uh why don't they maybe i
don't know that's a that's a
controversial thing to to ashley i don't
know
okay so so we mentioned a bit before
about um
the fact he doesn't predict this unique
state for the universe it predicts all
this
gargantuan number of possibilities
that's a weakness in in a way
some people might interpret that as a
virtue because when you've got so many
possibilities you're going to get one
that's compatible with what we see right
but it could also be described as a
weakness
i don't think it's fair to say it's not
really a testable theory i think i think
that's that's not true
and i think you can for example you
assume that the symmetries of special
relativity are present and if we find
any evidence that they're not then that
would be
a proof against string theory so it's
wrong to say that it's not um
that it that it's not
a testable theory another issue that
people might have with with string
theory for example would be um the
cosmological constant we know that we
see out there we see the universe
accelerating that requires a positive
cosmological constant just this
parameter in your in your physical
theory the vacuum energy of the universe
should be positive the engine when you
take everything out of the universe the
leftover energy it should be positive
that would be
compatible with this accelerating
universe that we see
string theory doesn't really like that
it prefers either zero or negative
that's not to say it can't necessarily
give you the positive one there are
some
ideas out there which try to construct
these these within string theory
they have been criticized in some
quarters
it's it's cutting-edge ongoing stuff
right
but that might be one perceived weakness
of string theory trying to get that
positive cosmological constant out but
yeah there are there are there is
serious work out there doing that and
indeed that claim to have done it is
there an ultimate test or proof is there
is there a silver bullet out there that
you could say look stream theorists were
right all along well i i think i think
there would be yeah i think i think so
at the moment so we talked about the
formula that this formula that sort of
uh virus or shapiro came up with that
does everything it needs to do right now
it's not been proved that that's the
unique choice that you could have made
right given all the criteria that you
want that it reproduces the right things
at low energies
and it doesn't introduce any pathologies
you know that violate quantum mechanics
and all that is it unique
we don't know if somebody comes along
and proves that it is unique
mathematically
which is this is a mathematical exercise
now
and then i think that's a feather that
it's kind of like it could only have
ever been string theory right
and you didn't have to do any experiment
to prove that or the only experiments
you need to prove that are the
experiments that confirm special
relativity and quantum mechanics
so that for me would would be it really
the other thing that string theory
typically needs is supersymmetry
so um if we found evidence of
supersymmetry then
that would be good for string theory
because we haven't found it it's not
going to be found at the lhc by looks of
it but that's not to say that string
theory is wrong it just means that the
supersymmetry kicks in at a higher
energy that the lhc can't see
so you have two types of particles in
nature you have bosons and fermions so
for example the higgs particle is is a
like a boson so is the photon is a boson
the graviton is a boson they're
characterized by the fact that they have
integer values of their spin it's like
an intrinsic spin and they have integer
values
there are also fermions
they have half integer spin so things
like the electron and what supersymmetry
does is it it postulates the symmetry
between these two kinds of particles so
for every boson you have a fermion for
every female you have a boson
and and
yeah that's what so it kind of doubles
up the number of particles but it
it's a very natural extension of the
symmetries that we know of the
the next step up would be that you would
include supersymmetry so again it's a
natural progression of ideas and string
theory requires it
because without it it predicts the it's
unstable
it is the natural path of all the ideas
that be built up of 20th century that in
a way string through the natural place
that you would go next so i don't think
you need a rewriting of anything i think
it'd be the opposite if string theory
was found to to somehow not be right
then you'd have to start thinking about
rewriting all the textbooks i think it
would be the other way around i mean the
other thing i suppose that people people
criticize string theory for of course is
that it's a theory it predicts the
dimensionality of the universe to be um
ten space-time dimensions
which you know you look outside and
there's there's four three dimensions of
space one dimension at a time so
where are the other six but but this
this is this you can easily you know you
can imagine that they're wrapped up very
small or that we live on a brain
membrane or something like that this is
not really an
see here you issue see how truly big it
is
i mean it's vast
you know and it's kind of i think it's
crazy if you think that
you know it's so big
and yet we're looking at something so
small security on to us they found out
we're breaking into the treasure boxes
it's okay sir this is authorized i'm
here with keith yes all right you're
gonna watch us open the box yes yes come
on then what's your name moses moses i'm
brady i'll get ready